now that were the EU referendum firmly
on the horizon a number of groups are
vying to lead the charge to leave Europe
the umbrella campaign leave EU is one of
those backed by the UK leader Nigel
Farage so much so that they've brought
on a standby team a strategy team sorry
from the United States i spoke to jerry
gun stir from günstig goddard down the
line from Washington yesterday and I
started by asking mr. Gunter if he was
confident they could achieve one unified
campaign I do think that there can be a
clear path to victory here clearly there
are competing organizations that are
trying to align themselves to be the
official leave EU campaign I'm frankly
quite impressed with what I'm seeing
from Lee vu right now with nearly
180,000 people that have signed up for
their organization they've got 50,000
people that are 150,000 people that are
on their facebook they're doing a great
good job on social media with fifteen
thousand followers so i think that when
the whistle is blown and we're ready to
take the field to begin a campaign i
think that leave EU is it a wonderful
position to begin this campaign well
okay well even if it is unified you've
got to give the voters that clear reason
why they should vote to leave the EU is
the core message as in so many ballots
going to pivot around the economy well
you know they typically do but let's
just for a second take a step back and
think about what a referendum campaign
is all about dermot that is all that I
do for a living I run referendum
campaigns I do not do candidate
campaigns I would certainly love to have
a conversation with you about the
difference between a candidate campaign
and a referendum campaign but let's talk
for a second if we can about a
referendum campaign ultimately when
voters go into the voting booth and
you'll have to excuse me the American
term isn't a voting booth we will go in
there and we all basically are human
and there are series of things that will
go through our hands number one is this
going to be good for my self interest my
family my budget my community my
school's my children and that is
ultimately what this vote is going to
come down to what is the self interest
for the UK voter to say I am comfortable
with leaving the current status quo and
leaving the EU and it is really
fundamental to who we are as human
beings what is the self interest for me
to choose to leave the EU the
personalities involved are hugely
important of course is it also essential
that the campaign has a clear figurehead
or figureheads giving out that message
well again let's talk about the
difference between a candidate that is
running for a campaign and a referendum
let's take for example a Hillary Clinton
a Donald Trump or any candidate that is
running for an office within 30 to 60
seconds you may be able to make a
decision on that person and frankly it
might be because you just didn't like
the way that their tie looked or you
didn't like the way that their hair
looked that particular day we don't know
with a referendum campaign you are
literally voting on words that are on a
piece of paper that have almost just
they're just words and so the trick here
and running a referendum campaign is how
do you take those words and turn them
into a personality now with referendum
campaigns that means that there are many
messengers I will say that if you're in
the Midlands you have a different
messenger than you would in the southern
part of the state I mean Dermot I have
heard your interviews where it's clearer
that there is a divide in the UK there
are different geographic and demographic
breakdowns that every group has to hear
from a messenger that they identify with
so I do not believe and I have I
told the folks at leave EU and they
generally agree with me this cannot be a
campaign run out of Westminster there
there is the possibility as they're not
fit for damage to some members of the
coalition of the leave EU campaign are
there's some parties that are going to
be rather tentative sharing platforms
with some of the other parties even
though they share the same end I believe
that as we move forward here people are
going to have to do their best to put
their differences behind I have the
utmost respect for all the political
leaders that were involved in the
Scottish referendum I have the utmost
respect for all the folks that are
involved in this campaign right now
again this is a referendum campaign and
the people of the United Kingdom are the
ones that are going to vote on this and
there can't be anything more exciting
than having the ability to vote on an
issue that is going to potentially
historically change the way that the
world looks at you and that is
ultimately this is not about the
political elites this is about the
people of the United Kingdom do you have
a slight problem though in getting the
parties together now in that the
referendum is not going to be held now
and will be held on slightly different
terms to those that exist at the moment
because it's going to be a renegotiation
with other members of the European Union
so therefore there may be some members
of the leave EU campaign at the moment
to actually like what they hear from the
Prime Minister when he comes back from
Brussels yeah look I mean this is
clearly a very complicated scenario that
we're dealing with and not all the
pieces of the puzzle have put to been
put together completely let completely
but we are in a marathon this is not a
sprint and right now we are on the very
early stages of a race and I will tell
you that whether this election is in
March or whether this election is going
to be next September or any time in
between a lot of these things that are
happening
right now with the different
disagreements about who's going to be
doing what and what the negotiations are
frankly aren't going to matter to the
voter because again they have a
self-interest they're going to go into
that voting booth and they're going to
make a decision on whether or not this
is good for me this is good for my
family this is good for my security and
ultimately as we say in the US is this
good for my pocketbook am I going to be
able to pay my taxes and pay my bills
and not only that but it is going to be
better for me Jerry gangster who's
advising the leave EU campaign now
coming up in the next hour on burnin